at the table the Sunday morning Norman
Solomon executive director of the
institute for public accuracy good
morning good to be here thank you for
joining us mr. Solomon his author of
this book target Iraq what the news
media didn't tell you mr. Solomon what
did the news media not tell us about all
this well a whole lot in real time when
it was quite possible to decipher a lot
of the deceptions that were put forward
by the governments of Tony Blair and
George W Bush the news media for the
most part I think engaged in stenography
they presented a few small doubts but
the overwhelming dominance of the
coverage was to simply take at face
value what the administration had to say
are there any particular examples that
shine out in your mind that you can
bring to us well definitely the two key
ones had to do with weapons of mass
destruction and the purported links
between the regime of Saddam Hussein and
the al-qaeda network and you didn't have
to be a rocket scientist or a social
scientist for that matter let alone a
particularly tough minded journalist to
see through the fabrications of the
material the inflation of supposed
threat the kind of shilly-shallying
around to imply a connection with
al-qaeda and the Baghdad regime without
preventing presenting real firm evidence
so in a nutshell you had a kind of
innuendo campaign in a repetition
campaign as though if Cheney Bush
Rumsfeld Powell would say it often
enough it somehow was allegedly true if
the media fell in line with the
government as you say why well this is a
critique that I've made and other media
critics have made for decades whether
the president has named Reagan Bush
Clinton or whoever there's a very strong
tendency for the Washington press corps
to gravitate towards power and i
remember in reading about conversation
decades ago between the late columnist
walter Lippmann and the late publisher
of The Washington Post where mr. Lippman
advised Katharine Graham never get too
far from the establishment well
generally the establishment is the power
of the majority in capitol hill and in
the White House and so
rather than providing independent
tough-minded journalism the Washington
press corps tends to provide on the
whole stenography for people and
powerful policymaking positions that's
not to say there aren't some fierce
criticisms and debate but when it comes
to foreign policy those debates coming
through the news media tend on balance
to be overwhelmingly a tactical dispute
how do we exert the power of the US
military around the world how does the
United States work its will on different
parts of the planet that's very
different from wide-ranging debate about
what is now I think clearly as most
people around the world perceive it a
very strong effort by the administration
of washing to Washington to essentially
enforce a kind of Pax Americana an
American Empire Norman Solomon will be
with us for about 35 or 40 more minutes
and here are the phone numbers if you
agree with President Bush's policies
called 2025 853 880 if you disagree with
mr. Bush 585 3881 is the number to call
and we have the international line open
2025 85 3883 mr. Solomon when we talk
about the media there's so much media
out there who in your opinion has done
the poorest job of all of this well in
terms of the war coverage i would say
that a lot of the worst coverage has
come from inside the TV studios and i
make that distinction because in my
three trips to baghdad since last summer
i talked to many hard-working
journalists including TV correspondents
for major US networks and generally they
were I think scrupulous about trying to
provide some strong reporting on the
ground journalism and so forth but quite
often it's back in Washington Atlanta at
New York where the major TV networks and
I'm not going to let any of them off the
hook in terms of cable CNN MSNBC Fox the
preponderance of the coverage in the
commentary has been very much too kind
of spin whatever the conventional wisdom
is along Pennsylvania Avenue and here
you know at the Capitol we've had many
many members of Congress who perhaps
known better who went along to get along
and they were willing to give the
benefits of the doubt to the Pentagon
and you would think and to the White
House one would think after several
decades in our lifetimes many of us of
seeing from Vietnam to this war the
deceptions that came out of foggy bottom
and the White House one would think that
skepticism would be appropriate to say
the least before we go to call Norman
Solomon who has done this well in terms
of covering the war I have to say the
best coverage of this war in the English
language has come out of Britain the
Guardian newspaper The Observer on
Sunday the independent daily newspaper
out of London and the BBC with
criticisms one might make still if you
were for instance to listen to the BBC
news and compare it to NPR All Things
Considered morning edition or watch BBC
television compared to the PBS newshour
with jim lehrer read the observer or the
independent or The Guardian in Britain
and then read The Washington Post The
New York Times and the LA Times which
we're told are our best journalistic
daily products you see a tremendous
contrast where there's there's an
enormous tendency reflected again and
again and what we see and hear and read
in the supposedly best media in the
United States a very strong tendency to
tint the window on the world red white
and blue to provide these essentially
stenography services for policymakers in
Washington that's not good journalism so
the better coverage i think has come out
of the British press calls for norman
solomon now Monroe Michigan you're up
first good morning good morning good
morning I'm wanted to discuss this
notion of the so-called Pax Americana
and the building of empire that you that
a lot of you on the Left refer to
constantly I'd like to know how it is
that we're building an empire in a
country where there's the infrastructure
has been pretty much destroyed on Tom
Friedman wrote who's not exactly a
raging right winger a few weeks ago that
it was good that we went into Iraq
excuse me so that we could establish
some sort of a foothold in that
to try to stabilize it somehow because
everybody in that region is supporting
terrorism all of the countries in the
Middle East all the Muslim countries are
supporting terrorism against this
country and many of our allies I fail to
see how this is empire building I think
that that is a it's just a flat-out ally
and I think it's unfair to the
administration well you're entitled to
your opinion I definitely 180 degrees
disagree with you as I said in my book
certainly Saddam Hussein with a vicious
tyrant there was no evidence that he was
involved in 911 no evidence of any
substantive ties with al-qaeda
whatsoever Thomas Friedman who passes
for some kind of liberal in the narrow
spectrum of us news media wrote in his
most recent book about what he said was
an ongoing dynamic he thought it was a
good thing he said to have McDonald's
around the world you need
mcdonald-douglas military contractors so
this is his vision of globalization
which is unfortunately very typical of
us news media that you have to deploy
the US military you have to enforce the
will of the White House through the US
Armed Forces and in point of fact if
we're going to look at Empire let's ask
ourselves a very simple question and try
to be honest about the answer let's
suppose that Iraq rather than having 112
billion barrels of known oil reserves
under the sand in that country had zero
oil not one drop of oil do we really
think a hundred and forty-six thousand
US troops would now be occupying Iraq I
don't think so and it's clear through
the history of the President and
vice-president of the United States
they're deeply entwined with the oil
industry and other corporate energy
sectors they're very happy and their
friends are very happy for the long-term
benefits of those corporations this is
in a sense now by the way the Enron
ization of the development of Iraq the
United States is the Conqueror now of
course the United States government
officials want peace the Prussian
general Carl von Klaus
it said two centuries ago with not a
little bit of irony every Conqueror
wants peace that is after the war has
been won and the Conqueror believes it
is possible to impose his will on
another population Tulsa Oklahoma good
morning yes good morning what seemed
really strange to me when there was a
debate going on about the whether or not
we should invade Iraq was that you had
the UN coming in UN inspectors basically
saying we can't really find anything yet
the French and the Germans agreeing yes
we should have more you know they should
be allowed more time and then the news
media started to say this is this the
end of the UN because they disagree with
us and it just it it didn't seem to be
any debate at all it was just we're
right everybody else is wrong and if I
didn't read The Observer if I didn't
look and search out for alternative
media to actually get a you know a
second opinion you know you can all you
can almost see why the American public's
just led down them you know down them
down the path of destruction it's really
strange thanks caller mentions
alternative media Norman Solomon what do
you think is the the best out there
perhaps on the Internet in terms of news
coverage well I think actually again the
British press there are some us sites
that help lead us to a lot of different
sources one of my favorites is called
common dreams org common dreams 0 RG at
our Institute where I work the Institute
for Public accuracy we have a website
just accuracy org the word accuracy o RG
and by the way we put out news releases
that are archived there that go back to
last July August september-october we're
contemporaneously in real time and it's
not that we're geniuses but we're able
to provide a debunking documentation of
how the vice president and president and
Powell and Rumsfeld were deceiving the
American people and striving to do so
one other thing about the caller's
question which i think is very key the
United Nations has a certain way of
being treated along Pennsylvania Avenue
the hill in the White House and also
generally in the u.s. news media if the
UN Security Council does what the White
House wants it to do then we're told
that a new era of enlightenment and
relevance has been ushered in by the UN
if however that world body exercises
some independence as it should and
functions as a genuine assembly of
governments from around the world and
doesn't do the bidding of Washington
then we're told that the UN is becoming
irrelevant it risks being consigned to
the dustbin of history that was a
constant theme last summer last fall
last winter when Colin Powell went on
februari second of this year and gave
his presentation with the photos and
circles and arrows and satellite
depictions and so forth he was deceiving
not only the UN but the people in the
United States nothing he said of
substance has been borne out in the last
two-plus months of occupation and yet it
was the United States media that went
along on the whole to praise that
presentation which in retrospect we know
was quite mendacious let me get your
take on this Norman Solomon you
mentioned the BBC a couple of times the
post has distorted a British government
clashes with BBC there's a picture here
the Prime Minister Tony Blair and
Alastair Campbell his director of
communications it says that the Prime
Minister and his government is locked in
an unusually bitter and personal
struggle with the BBC over the accuracy
of a journalist report that the
government distorted intelligence
information in its dossier on Iraq's
weapons of mass destruction what's your
take on this whole issue we've been
hearing about well it was in London a
few weeks ago and it was quite notable
that the mainstream British press was so
much more outraged at the evidence of
Tony Blair's deception then what we have
experienced in the last few weeks in the
United States in terms of media coverage
of the deceptions of the Bush
administration and I think it's worth
mentioning that this morning's Observer
newspaper in London reports that the
head of m16 the British intelligence
agency briefed the BBC quite a while ago
before the war
and indicated there were other countries
that were if anything much more of a
threat than the Iraqi regime towards the
west the British on the United States I
think one of the things that has
infuriated so many people in Britain is
that there was an intelligence circle
from the United States to Britain to
some extent it appears from Israel the
Mossad and so forth routing through
Washington and London and those books
were cooked in terms of intelligence
data I find a lot of American and if
they supported the war at the time
they're getting rather upset to think
that this war went forward based on lies
coming out of washington st. george's
delaware for norman solomon good morning
yeah I seem to recall that they were
required by their concessions after the
war over their invasion of Kuwait to
dismantle and disarm and destroy all
there's no weapons of mass destruction
and a research programs and as such 12
years of the hide-and-seek and running
around the the inspectors keeping them
at bay outside of sites that they were
inspecting while they've got trucks
going out of back entrance um and
they've built all kinds of underground
bunkers and things like that secretly in
an area the size of California I believe
I've heard and a few weeks ago when the
first critics started coming out with
their protests about their no no
evidence of weapons of mass destruction
and things like that they started
curtailing the inspections and they
still had a couple hundred sites to look
look out I bleed call her move this
forward into a question if you could uh
what I'm it's not so much a question but
a statement I regicide just think that
people are forgetting the fact
he was known to be doing the research he
was known to have produced anthrax and
and some of these other chemical
biological agents all right we got the
point Colin part of his the passive
voice he was known he was known by who
and if you look at this speech is made
for instance March seventeenth just a
couple days before the all-out usuk war
on iraq began a President Bush made a
huge important speech to the American
people saying things that we know are
absolutely false saying point blank the
US and other governments knew there were
these weapons of mass destruction of
major proportions in Iraq there's a
mythology that somehow the United
Nations inspection process was not being
productive it's a mythology that's been
debunked by hans blix by others involved
in the inspection process and if you
look at the actual history of inspection
you found a lot of progress going on in
the 1990s some inspectors including
scott ritter saying ninety to
ninety-five percent of the weapons being
destroyed you had a defector kamal in
the mid 90s in jordan being debriefed we
found out only years later he said iraq
had destroyed their weapons of mass
destruction sometime after the gulf war
and one more point that i think is very
important here if you look at the
factual information cited by people like
Donald Rumsfeld and Democrats including
Senator John Kerry in the run-up to this
latest war a last fall last winter you
see them repeating something that was an
absolute lie repeated as well by many
journalists from virtually all major
media outlets and we document this in
our book and that is the idea the claim
that in December of 1998 the Iraqi
regime kicked out the UN weapons
inspectors the unseen it's just an
empirical fact we all have a right to
our opinions we don't all have a right
to make up facts and if you look in the
archives of the simultaneous coverage in
December of 1998 you find that
absolutely the Iraqis did not kick out
the UN weapons inspectors they were
withdrawn
under pressure of the US government by
the head of that team a mr. Butler just
prior to the bombings of Iraq for a few
days known as Operation Desert Fox
informally known as Operation Monica
Lewinsky because it was right before the
impeachment process here on the hill so
again this is just history that's
refabricated and frankly made up and in
retrospect when you see now the absence
of weapons of mass destruction turning
up in occupied iraq it makes that fact
all the more significant let's go to
Stafford Virginia now for Norman Solomon
hello good morning I'm wondering about
the alternatives it seems to me in a
country of free enterprise why one of
the news or media moguls doesn't come up
with some sort of nonpartisan news
network to me it's it's really a joke
we've got American lives being
endangered in Iraq I know I've got a 13
year old son I'm very concerned about
the world today caller you mentioned
you'd like to see a nonpartisan news
network way to get most your news now
from um everywhere I get a murder I get
Fox ABC NBC and you know it's sort of
like Pro Wrestling you know it's
Democrats Republicans left right you
know it's like pulling for football
teams it disgust me we're talking about
human lives thanks mr. song yeah i think
that the coverage is very narrow you've
got on the very the far right fox news
channel and fox news for instance where
the real motto should be we distort you
decide and then you have across that
very narrow spectrum an outlet like CNN
i have no grudge against them i appeared
on that network now and again but it's
very much repeating almost like a
repeater service for the official line
coming out of washington in terms of
Foreign Affairs and frankly I've talked
with journalists including a network
journalist in Baghdad were very
frustrated because they realized that
whatever reporting they do on the ground
from Iraq is kind of overridden or
swamped
by the very intense spin which puts
forward the administration's perspective
and in the absence of strong voices
coming from Capitol Hill to challenge
some of the deceptive claims and
assertions then you have simply a kind
of a quasi-government News Service
Norman Solomon is executive director of
the Institute for Public accuracy that
tells more about your background yeah my
work is as an investigative reporter and
more recently as a researcher and our
Institute for Public accuracies been
around for about seven years we really
are trying to serve as kind of a counter
way too much more heavily funded think
tanks like heritage Cato American
Enterprise Brookings which run the gamut
from about a to see their very corporate
backed and corporate friendly they've
got a lot of friends in high elite
places we're trying to provide
documentation and perspectives that can
fill out the picture you said you went
to Iraq three times I think one of those
times was with the actor Sean Penn
because right actually a last
september's went with representative
Nick Rahall a congressman from West
Virginia he's been in the house for
about 26 years now then with Sean Penn
and December and then in late January of
this year I went with the former head of
the UN oil-for-food program Dennis
Halliday to Baghdad as well what was the
biggest surprise that you learned when
you were there I think of everything the
most powerful transformation for me was
to sit down and talk with Iraqi people
in what was certainly at that time a
police state under a very repressive
regime what was most surprising was not
he would say intellectual so much is
more emotional to realize that while we
have these kind of stick figure almost
media images of what Iraqi people are
they had been suffering for many years
in the aftermath of the first Gulf War
and it was a jolt to realize at a more
human level that in my name with my tax
dollars there had been so much suffering
inflicted on people in Iraq and a sense
and I did this the other way I put it
they were hostages of Saddam Hussein and
the u.s. imposed horrific sanctions and
then bombed the hostages 25 million
people in Iraq to questions about Sean
Penn was he used by the Iraqi government
at the end of his visit and what did you
make of the US media coverage of that
trip yeah well Sean Penn went of his own
volition out of I think a very deep
concern as a father of two children and
connecting with the importance of other
young people in the United States and
Iraq and elsewhere having a future and
so I don't think he was used he went in
with his eyes open as he said I was born
at night but not last night he wrote an
open letter to President Bush October of
last year that ran as a full-page ad in
The Washington Post where he said
explicitly in the open letter that the
regime of Saddam Hussein was vicious and
tyrannical so he had made that statement
very publicly before he went to Iraq and
he went because he believed there should
be exploration of alternative to simply
dropping a lot of bombs on a lot of
people as he said when we visited a
children's hospital there many kids
dying of leukemia and cancer not able to
get drugs because of the UN imposed
sanctions and people often misunderstand
that the US State Department was able to
veto and did veto specific chemotherapy
drugs and at that point he he said you
know you go to the Children's Hospital
you see these kids many of them are
dying you don't want a door to slam let
alone have a two thousand-pound bomb
fall in the neighborhood which is what
happened a few months after our visit in
terms of us media coverage you know the
Rupert Murdoch press went crazy they
started calling him Baghdad Sean before
he even left Iraq but we found you know
that there was also some pretty deep
understanding among the European press
and John Burns of the New York Times
wrote I think a very well thought out
long article in The Times about his
visit so that the media coverage was was
kind of mixed I have to note that Arnold
Schwarzenegger has been in Iraq in the
last couple
days and quite a contrast to Sean Penn
you know Penn went there I think with a
lot of sensitivity and attention to
nuance he knew he wasn't in a movie he
knew his in real life dealing with the
lives of many precious people Americans
and Iraqis Arnold Schwarzenegger has
been there talking to the Troops
spouting out Hollywood clichés it's get
a some more calls in here we have about
15 minutes left caller from Holland this
morning thank you for waiting yes a good
morning I was liberated personally by
the Americans in 1945 I must say so I
was very pro-american all my life and
now seeing Murdoch's Channel News Fox
takes only five minutes to make me an
anti-american how does yes well I've
heard similar comments from many people
400 million people here yeah during my
visit to Britain a few weeks ago talking
to other people from Europe really a
ghast at this enormous gap in the kind
of media coverage we generally get in
the United States which is chauvinistic
which is arrogant which seems to feel
that the United States can do no wrong
by definition the president is angelic
and dispatches as little angels around
the world in uniform these angelic
creatures that are ordered by the
commander-in-chief to drop these
horrific bombs on often populated areas
give you one example the cluster
munitions which are still in Iraq some
of them unexploded dropped and fired by
the US Army sometimes exploding in the
hands of little children who pick them
up this is a reality the associated
press reported it on june twenty third
of this year not a lot of play and i
think for instance in britain there's a
lot more coverage of that reality and
that helps explain why the pew research
center and other polling organizations
see this enormous distance in
perspective in in Holland or Britain or
really almost anywhere else on earth
there's a much more critical and I'm
sorry to say discerning perspective and
critique of u.s. foreign policy than we
tend to get from US news media
we call from russell springs Kentucky
this morning hi good morning morning I
want to comment on your speaker I've in
total agreement I'm 72 years old I was
landed it in China and Korea went
through this whole thing all of a sudden
now it's an evil empire what concerns me
more is that the right-wing
conservatives historically even during
the Eisenhower administration would you
disagreed with American policy that we
had the great purge in which the
McCarthy hearings were you were
absolutely unpatriotic and even Reagan
who became president when he was the
president of Screen Actors Guild the if
you were labeled if you disagreed with
American policy you were a pinky and the
lives that were destroyed if I were a
sama bin Laden I would be reveling that
a man that they can't even find could
trigger and set forth in this country
the absolute decimation of our
fundamental rights of trial of being
held wake up America we fought for
freedom and this they have always bush
and it's right I agree with mr. song but
get the points of views of the rest of
the world thanks any reaction yeah I
think the concern about the abrogation
of civil liberties in this country is
well taken in many respects John
Ashcroft and George Bush have been doing
what sama bin Laden could not of his own
effort and that is to so damaged the
realities of the civil liberties
environment in this country and the
so-called Patriot Act that was passed
now effort to even go farther than that
the reality is I think that if you want
to have an effective foreign policy in
the long run you need to have a single
standard of human rights were against
killing of civilians for political
purposes colin powell was quite right on
the day of 911 it's reprehensible for
people to
think that they should kill civilians
destroy buildings kill people for
political purposes to kill
non-combatants in that way such wanton
horrific murderous way that al-qaeda did
and yet since then we know that the US
government through predictable actions
predictable results of their military
endeavors in Afghanistan and now in Iraq
in each country killed more civilians
than those who died on 911 you don't
effectively fight terrorism by
terrorizing people and the fact is that
the US military by using just for one
example these cluster munitions that are
now terrorizing children and others in
Iraq that's a form of terrorizing people
so in a nutshell I would say that if
we're going to challenge terrorism let's
stop the US government by continuing the
cycles of violence and murder of
civilians the reality is if you want to
fight terrorism you've got to have a
single standard and I would just close
with this al Qaeda is a horrific
violator of Human Rights a horrific
regime de facto non national
organization in terms of imposing and
inflicting terrorism the Pentagon is
also inflicting terrorism and we as
Americans need to challenge that besides
Iraq what do you make of media coverage
of other issues regarding the president
in the White House other decisions
besides Iraq yeah well i think that the
president on the whole has gotten a free
pass in the last couple of years he's
able to do enormous amounts of
accomplishments you might say implement
a lot of successes on the hill that
benefit the rich i mean every time
there's a new tax cut going through it
further undermines the well-being of
middle class and the poor not only
through tilting much more of a tax code
advantage towards the wealthy and
corporations but also decimating our
state's i mean no matter where anybody
is in this country watching this program
right now you find out what your state
budget
looks like your localities your health
care your Social Services your school's
you find them being decimated and this
is the attitude out of Washington on the
whole that it's okay to decimate the
states let's make a mess let people at
the local areas clean it up let's go to
Liverpool England thanks for hanging on
hello Thank You c-span well I'd like to
agree with this man so much she speaking
so much then and I'd also like to reduce
the comments who's just made about
terrorism I think the invasion of Iraq
was the biggest recruitment for al-qaeda
ever and if we do not address ignorance
greed and poverty the world I mean he
made the comments about the media and
several of the call of how previous the
right-wing greedy need you I will
continue to feed the way all the images
they want them to know so as these
people follow them like sheep you know
all this greedy advertisers and shallow
superficial way of life causes a lot of
bloodshed reviled crown so is the greedy
fat capitalist it can hold on tight to
the reins of power it doesn't matter to
them how many people die or suffer just
so they can go to their fancy
restaurants drive the fancy cars you
know despite the pollution killing us
and the greed appreciate you calling
let's move around on a fife lake
michigan good morning hello caller hit
the mute button on your set please yeah
I'm go ahead I'd like to ask your client
about his political background and his
college and intellectual background he
seems to be against the United States it
seems to be a situation where we're just
not supposed to do anything and we're
just supposed to sit back and believe
everything he says and everything
anybody says along his lines I mean
can't we judge him by the company he
keeps he hangs out with Sean Penn not
exactly one of the intellectual brains
of the Western world let's get a
response from mr. Solomon well by the
way if you'd sat down and talked to Sean
Penn as I did you'd find that he'd done
extensive study about Iraq and I
certainly would take his perspective
about Iraq over many in Washington who
in their air-conditioned offices say
this occupation is going just fine but I
think much more fundamentally and maybe
intrinsic to your question is the idea
that if you challenge the President of
the United States you're somehow against
America I would have thought we could
have retired that absurd canard a long
time ago I'm old enough to remember
during the Vietnam War when during
nineteen 65 66 67 68 as hundreds of
thousands of US troops were deployed to
Southeast Asia we were told by people
who sounded very similar to this collar
that those of us who didn't like it
should sit down and shut up that we
shouldn't speak up that we shouldn't
protest and in light of history the
notion that Americans should protect our
precious freedoms by not exercising them
is preposterous the First Amendment is
about use it or lose it and those who
want to change the direction of this
country I believe should use it op-ed
piece by Joseph C Wilson the fourth the
US ambassador to go bone from 1990 to
295 now an international business
consulted he writes in the new york
times today i was convinced before the
war that the threat of weapons of mass
destruction in the hands of saddam
hussein required a vigorous and
sustained international response to
disarm him iraq possessed and had used
chemical weapons it had an active
biological weapons program and quite
possibly a nuclear research program all
of which were in violation of UN
resolutions having encountered mr.
Hussein and his thugs in the run-up to
the Persian Gulf War I was only too
aware of the dangers he posed Joe Wilson
writes on that but these but were these
the dangers the same ones the
administration told us about we have to
find out America's foreign policy
depends on the sanctity of the
information for this reason questioning
the selective use of intelligence to
justify the war in Iraq is neither idle
sniping nor revisionist history as mr.
Bush's suggested the act of war is the
last option of a democracy taken when
there is a grave threat to our national
security more than 200 American soldiers
have lost their lives in Iraq already we
have a duty to ensure that their
sacrifice came for the right reasons
Amanda
Joe Wilson will be one of the guests on
meet the press today on NBC we're moving
on to London welcome to the program
hello there I just wanted to make two or
three quick points basically that you
talk about your guest talks about being
identity Afghanistan war as well as the
Iraq war but I would argue present which
had no choice for that feminist on some
the 11 however what now loves you
supposedly just say the American me were
by the way not to notice how Afghanistan
they would have lynched him for that he
wouldn't have been reelected secondly if
he looked at President Bush's policies
they're actually different from Reagan's
because he's actually a reverse most of
the most of the decentralization which
Reagan did taking away from Washington
Bush with his homeland security it is
actually where a lot of the centralized
a should that happen before raid and
he's reversed that he's actually a a
centralized and not a decentralized a
bush and her sadly Iraq ISM is an
occupation the problem is of the US stop
treating it like sort of Disneyland
actually started running a country
seriously I see US troops they look like
they're on holiday there rather than
doing anything mr. yes something yeah I
would agree that the current Bush
administration has really centralized
power it's rather curious for
conservatives that they would give so
much repressive leverage and power to
the Attorney General and to Washington I
thought that we were supposed to protect
the public from intrusive government
power it seems that the so-called
conservatives are actually allowing
government to be more and more intrusive
into people's personal lives from what
they check out at the library to what
they say to each other in email in a
nutshell about the occupation of Iraq
you know that is going to increasingly
founder for many of the same reasons
that we now know the case for the war
initially was deceptive and that is
wishful thinking coming out of the
Pentagon and white house that you can
simply pull this off because you're
Americans that the hell with the people
on the ground and one more key point
it's about priorities because the US
administration the White House has made
clear that its priorities are about
securing the oil fields and securing and
maintaining political control appointees
to run the country is the plan from Paul
Bremer the administrator democracy is
not on the agenda as far as Washington
is concerned more on domestic issue here
big one regarding the media what's your
reaction of the FCC's changes on media
ownership rules very important it's
quite a service rendered to the huge
corporate media outlets such as Fox News
Channel such as many other multi-billion
dollar conglomerates that need favors
from Washington need them from the White
House and Capitol Hill the Senate
Commerce Committee because of the outcry
at the grassroots is on record as trying
to push through reversal of these
egregious measures adopted June second
by the FCC we need to safeguard the
airwaves the FCC by a three to two
margin participated in giving away more
of the airwaves to private interest
airwaves that are supposed to belong to
the public and we'd better organize to
challenge this corporate process that is
hijacking what's supposed to belong to
all of us which is the public airwaves
couple minutes left with Norman Solomon
sake it's West Indies thank you for
calling good morning thank you for
taking the call that my sister brief
observation that the a great chunk of
the tax cuts that president bush is
giving will end up right in Republican
covers for the upcoming presidential
campaign when his friends in the
Republican establishment throughout the
United States who are big fat cats if
you will go to these twenty thousand
dollar to create dinners and put them
straight back into his campaign fund
there's something cynical about that
thank you let me say that I was not a
supporter of President Clinton not a
supporter of Bill Clinton but to see
what this bush white house is doing to
rip off the American people to make the
rich even richer is really outrageous
and we need to
be clear about what's taking place and
try to change the situation pauls valley
Oklahoma oh I thought I would never get
on go ahead rings uh I was wondering you
know I've been asking what happened to
the investigative journalist because all
we were getting is the White House bin
and from the media all the media there
is no other alternative and you can't
get to the real truth because they're
busy promoting the lies that the Bush
administration said and also it's no
need and talking to the Republicans
because they've been marching lock
stepping behind Bush ever since he took
office they don't have a brain they
don't think and they just listen to
whatever he says and you know you have
to tell the Republicans what to think
because they don't know what to think
until the president tell well let me
just dissent from one part of your
statement I think Republicans definitely
have brains I wish that more Republicans
and for that matter Democrats would
recall what the Republican President
Dwight Eisenhower said in 1953 and I'll
paraphrase but pretty close paraphrase
to a statement he said every battleship
every plane every bullet is in a real
sense of theft from the children of the
world and this administration is engaged
in an enormous heist against the
children of this world and the planet
that's true that the tax system that
they're implementing its through their
expenditures what they're spending on
the military what they're not willing to
spend on human needs cumberland maryland
our last call good morning good morning
yes well i listened to mr. Solomon I
feel as if I'm listening to the voice of
Pravda pre Gorbachev oh how so pardon
how so I really feel I'm listening to
almost a communist a left-wing Leninist
point of view the tax on America the
attacks on the American media they sound
just like something out of prop de
rigueur [ __ ] oh well you know I was due
respect it sounds as though you're stuck
in some kind of time warp and of course
the repression of the Soviet Union was
horrific
the repression of all regimes that deny
people's free speech and political
rights always should be opposed the
reality though is that if you talk to
many Europeans as I do they're very
struck and someone who is a refugee from
a former communist country told me the
other day reading our major daily
newspapers quite often these days
reminds them of Pravda because of this
deference to the official line coming
out of the top government offices so to
really challenge the abrogation of human
and civil rights and liberties we need
to be willing to speak out and speak up
Norman Solomon is executive